Hãy gió thời gian tới, thành hình thây giới tiếp tục diệm biến phức tạp nhiều biến đồng.
Thủ đứng lên mình hơn đen nghị.
Conuì, chúng ngân bộ có phòng tiếp tục nân cao trước lượng tham biểu chến lợc về quan sử
quốc phòng vào đối ngoại.
Con đổi và nhìn xa hơn, trên bị sớm hơn, tham buồn sâu hơn.
Không chỉ giữ báo về quan sử quốc phòng mà cả tắc động về kinh tế xa hội ngoại xa nói chung.
Nhận dẹn các mùi cửa nền chuẩn thống, phi chuẩn thống.
Không để đất nước bị bắt nợ chến lợc.
Không để giữa kẹn với ngoài truyền hóa thành khùng hạn trong lợc.
Thủ tính lưu ý, phải tiếp tục xây dừng con đổi cách mạng chính quyền tinh rệ và hiện nay.
Thực hiện đều trình tổ chức bộ tiêu chiế xây dừng con đổi hiện đại trong tình hình mới.
Nên cao trước lượng mỗi lượt đong tạo diễn tập, làm chủ bú kỹ, chăng bị hiện đại và đáp ứng điều kẹn tắc trên mới.
Mà vệ vấn chắc chục quyền biến đào, biến dưới, vùng chơi, không ra mạng, hạ tăng chến lợc
và sử lý tình hỗng phải kinh quyết biến quyến tắc.
Lính hoạt về khương pháp, chắc chắn về pháp lý, chủ đồng về chuyến thông và chánh mắc bệ liều thang.
Cùng về đó theo tủ tưởng vài phát triển công nghiệp Quốc phòng từ chủ tượng lực thực tượng lưỡng giục và hiện đại.
Trời thành mỗi nhỏ của công nghiệp Quốc ra và làm chủ công nghiệp Quốc phòng,
chủ cùng những chiến lợc để bao đảng lực ứng phó trong mọi tình hỗng, trong tâm là đột phá phát triển qua học công nghệ lượt mới sáng tạo.
Thủ tưởng nhắn mạnh yêu cầu quan tâm thực hiện tốt tổng tắc chính sách và tổ chức trù đáo chẳng trọng các hoạt động đến ở đất nhá.
Chiar nhắn kiến nghiệp vài mi chiến lắm ngày thương viên liệt sĩ và đất biệt lợt thực hiện kế hoài
vài chính trình giống tối kiện nhận tám biến năm ngày thương viên liệt sĩ.
Đông thấy ruy động sức mạnh tổng hợp và nâng cao hiệu quả tiến kiếm quy tập hải cót liệt sĩ.
Thủ thập túng tín và sách định dành tính liệt sĩ.
Cói đây là nhận vụ chính trị đặt biệt quan trọng của các cấp các ngành nhất là vụ cuộc phòng và các quan thường trực của bán trị đạo
quốc gia về tiến kiếm quy tập và sách định dành tính hải cót liệt sĩ.
Thủ tưởng nè mình hương tiến tưởng rằng thời gian tởi sụ tình hình kế sợi còn nhờ thích thức và có tắc đậu sâu sắc đến lất nước ca.
Con độ nhân dân Việt Nam sẽ tiếp tục phát triển thống Anh Hồng, khoan thành xuất sách mọi nhận vụ được dau.
Lập nhiều chiến công thành tích xuất sắc hình được, và đúng có quan trọng hình được trong sự nghiệp xây dật phát triển và phọt về tụ quốc.